good morning everybody
ah we've got a lot of stuff to build
this week big stuff so I'm gonna start a
little bit earlier I don't have a list
this week but I met with Doug and he
talked to me about a bunch of the bigger
ticket items that he needs made to this
review so yeah let's convene over at the
workbench drink a little more coffee and
we'll talk about okay so for this week's
review in addition to the usual like
costume stuff I don't think there's
gonna be a lot of heavy makeup or
anything like that in this review but
Doug did need some bigger stage pieces
he had mentioned to me initially that
you were probably gonna need the basket
of a hot-air balloon
I thought that was a key element but we
met and showed me all the shots and
stuff like that that he wanted in
advance because we're recreating
something that already exists that we've
kind of already had all the shots and
stuff like that to look at and one of
the trickier elements is the balloon
basket and the actors and everything
have to be able to rotate 360 degrees in
order to do that obviously I have to
build the full basket and it has to be
able to rotate easily enough and sturdy
enough for three actors so that's gonna
be a bit of a challenge in the time
constraints that we have in addition to
that we also need to build a staircase
that again can accommodate three actors
and it has to be small enough to fit on
the green-screen
stage like and there so we can shoot it
but also
can't be too big or too high because
ceiling only goes to about ten feet in
that room or at least the screen only
goes to about ten feet but building the
stair shouldn't be that difficult it's
just going to be some basic construction
and today I'm just gonna start doing
that because that'll be easy and I can
think about how I want to build the
basket and the rotation situation so
we're just gonna jump right in and yeah
I don't know well just like always we'll
just see what happens
all right so our stairs are complete
very basic Doug is going to green-screen
it and basically animate the stairs or
use a cutout or drawing for whenever
there's the Sacketts stairs or whatever
so we don't really need to do anything
special to it it's pretty much done
I don't know if he wants me to paint in
green that's something I can do or if he
wants me to put out take the side on the
side just go painted green you can do
that too but yeah for now
stairs are done let's try and tackle
that whole rotating balloon that's good
thing
all right well just finished a couple
more coats of green paint on the green
screen
according to Duggar be filming stuff a
lot of its going to be showing the floor
and the floor was actually getting
really scuffed up and kind of dingy
looking so yeah so a fresh coat of paint
dad nice and clean and I'm gonna get
back to doing some other stuff okay so
here's my plan
I've got that round piece of board it's
about 4 feet circle should be big enough
for three actors stand on all ends and
make it rotate so I'm gonna do is I have
these fixed casters 8 of them I find the
center point mark it all off to 8 points
attach these so that there they go in a
circle and then I'm going to create a
box that is the height of the casters
which is two and a half inches and
attach a lazy susan
so that you can rotate and evidently the
same access and then this these should
give it the support on the outside so
that it doesn't flip over or anything
like that and it also helps it rotate so
that's the plan
in theory I think it should work so I'm
just gonna build it and see what happens
so let's try it
okay so as you can see it's actually
supporting my weight I can walk to the
edge and it doesn't flip up or cup over
so that part is working really good I
think then definitely just building the
box and add an editing the lazy susan
give it a head of support in the center
and a great access point to mount that
box then to surface underneath and then
we can just attach a strap on one end
and pull it off screen and it should
rotate without shifting side to side
anything like that and yeah that should
probably do the trick thank goodness
because I don't have much time to
experiment here
all right so as you can see it works or
at least good enough for our purposes
all right so the structure of the basket
is ready now my idea to kind of make it
look like a basket is to take some foam
that we have a big sheets of foam I'm
gonna cut them into strips and basically
weave a basket out of it and then wrap
it and paint it and hopefully it looks
enough like the best good of a hot-air
balloon I think I can add some material
stuff to the top throw some sandbags
over it and stuff like that
it pulls and it should put your back the
right way to put it on the rotating base
and yeah pretty much go command all
right
all right so this is basically how it'll
look I don't need to do the entire piece
for the full-size basket I think just
getting the corners the front is enough
so I don't have to do any more work than
I need to so I think I'm good with the
bottom half I just have to finish the
top half it goes all the way around and
then attach everything paint it paint
the poles and then there's just a few
other minor things we got to do some
little props I still have to break the
ropes
right pretty much done on this wait for
two more of the poles to dry it kind of
sort of Mokpo make the illusion of ropes
I guess but yeah see I just built this
corner the side is open so the actors
can go in and out much easier and you
really only need that corner or the
front and then the top part because it
detaches and from there so then this is
360 all the way around so that we can do
it for certain shots where we need to
see the 360 and it's an extra scrap
material that I just ran along the top
kind of give it that look at the inside
of the basket like it's aligned with
something
yeah all right
so talk to Doug earlier today and
basically he said that the stairs need
to be green so that it's easier to key
out and everything so that's what we did
in the stairs Green's Barney came in for
a few hours and poked me with some of
the he put the a on the Elven costume
and the hat and cut some green poster
board or foam board to act as the risers
the stairs so I didn't have to build
anything else
but painted the green and the lazy susan
I just painted green just in case so
yeah I think that's all that's left is I
have to Casper gap today I need to build
a harp kind of thing whatever
I think Doug is gonna play like a harp
like it's a guitar or something so I'm
just gonna cut a pattern out on this
piece of foam and cut it out real quick
paint it and it'll be it go over here
wherever it is that would be the heart
drop
then bored it's kind of supposed to look
I think like stone and stuff anyway like
he pulls it off my statue so all the
dings and marks and stuff I think we'll
just add to it and yes it's gonna cut it
out and paint it call her -
all right so I've listed a piece of
dowel or something it's a plastic for
wood across the top run some bogus
strings through it throw a paint job on
it it'd be good enough
alright that's about it for today
I retired I have a few things I still to
do a few things that are drying paint
wise I'll touch up and I'll come in
early in the morning finish up all the
last little odds and ends what I need to
alter a change or set up or whatever so
yeah I'm just gonna go home and look
over my lines I guess and try and
memorize this song that I have to
lip-synch to tomorrow morning so alright
well all in a day's work
you
yes yeah here we go are we looking into
the camera I'm sorry no you actually hit
your body okay thank you
yeah
go